[موسيقى]
بعد جوله اقتران شديده التنافس لم ينجح اي
من المرشحين لانتخابات الرئاسه التركيه في
الحصول على نسبه الحسم المطلوبه وهي 50%
زائد واحد حيث اقترب الرئيس اردوغان من
نسبه الحسم بفارق ضئيل يقل عن نصف بالمئه
بينما حصل منافسه في الجدار اوغلو على اقل
من 45 بالمئه وذهبت باقي الاصوات التي
زادت على الخمسه بالمئه بقليل الى
المتنافس الثالث سنانوها بهذه النتيجه
اصبحت تركيا على موعد في الثامن والعشرين
من هذا الشهر مع جوله الاعاده لحسم السباق
الرئاسي بين مرشح تحالف الجمهور الرئيس
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان ومرشحي تحالف
الشعب المعارض كمال الاجدار اوه فما هي
حدود كل من الطرفين استنادا الى عناصر
القوه التي سيعتمد عليها كل منهما لترجيح
كفته والى اي طرف ستذهب اصوات سنانوغان
وتحالف الاجداد الذي يمثله اهلا بكم في
هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اذا يسعى كل من المتنافسين
المتنافسين بالاحرى الرئيس اردوغانو فيما
تبقى من ايام معدودات على خوض جوله
الاعاده الى توظيف اقصى طاقاتهما ومحاوله
تلافي بعض الاخطاء وعقد مزيدا من
التحالفات والتفاهمات املا بالفوز بمقعد
رئاسه
لمحاوله استشراف حظوظ كل من الطرفين في 28
من الشهر الجاري يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في
هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور علي
بكير الخبير في الشان التركي واستاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في مركز ابن خلدون في
جماعه قطر من اسطنبول عمر فاروق كركمانس
الكاتب والباحث في الشان التركي ومن انقر
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي يوسف اهلا بهم
جميعا
يحتدم الجدل السياسي في تركيا قبيل جوله
ثانيه من انتخابات رئاسيه مثيره قد تشكل
علامه فارقه في تاريخ البلاد وقد بدا
المرشحان العمل على حشد المؤيدين واستماله
المترددين في سباق الانتخابي يزيد اشتعالا
الوضع الاقتصادي وقضيه اللاجئين
[موسيقى]
تمضي تركيا الى اول جوله اعاده الانتخابات
الرئاسه في تاريخها
صرحت ميا على الرجلين ان يعيدا حشد
انصارهما من نقطه البدايه لكن الاهم الان
هو استماله مزيد من الناخبين المترددين او
من انصار المرشحين اللذين خرج من السباق
يعتقد انصار الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ان
حسم الانتخابات لصالح مرشحهم ليس سوى
مساله وقت ففارق الاربع نقاط مئويه بينه
وبين منافسه كمالك الجدار اوغلو يمنحه
ارتياحا نسبيا لكنه رغم ذلك بحاجه الى
مزيد من الاصوات ومهمه خصمه الان هي قطع
الطريق امامه باعاده هيكله تحالف المعارضه
واحياء اعمال التواقين للتغيير هل ينجح
كمالك لجدار اوغلو في ذلك
يبدو مرشح تحالف الشعب المعارض احوج ما
يكون لاصوات مؤيدي سنان اوغان مرشح
التحالف الاجداد الذي جمع على نحو اللافت
اكثر من خمسه في المئه من الاصوات لكن
مازق يكمن في تحالفه مع حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي المتهم بعلاقه عضويه مع حزب
العمال الكردستاني والمعروف عن التيار
الذي ينتمي اليه اوغان انه قومي متشدد
يقدس وحده الاراضي التركيه
لاوغان من اجل دعم كليجدار اوغلو شروطه
لكنها ان اخرجته من مازق اوقعته في مازق
جديد فاذا استجاب لشرط التخلي عن التحالف
مع حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي فقد يكسب اصوات
مؤيدي اوغان لكنه سيخسر نسبه مهمه من
اصوات الاكراد لا يواجه اردوغان حسابات
معقده من هذا القبيل هو ليس في الواقع
بحاجه الى كل اصوات مؤيدي اوغان بل الى
نسبه منها
ولكسب مزيد من الاصوات قد يستغل جناحه
ايضا غضب مؤيدي المنسحب من سباق الرئاسه
محرم انجاه من تحالف الشعب المعارض الذي
كان وراء انسحاب مرشحهم اليوم يجددار
اوغلو وعده بترحيل جميع اللاجئين من تركيا
في غضون عامين ان فاز بالرئاسه ويقول ان
اردوغان اغرق البلاد بعشره ملايين منهم
ويتهمه بشراء مؤيدين له من خلال منح
الجنسيه التركيه للاجانب في مقابل ذلك غرد
اردوغان على حسابه في تويتر مستهجنا سلوك
بعض البلديات التي تقودها احزاب المعارضه
المؤيده
بقطعها مساعدات كانت تمنح للمتضررين من
الزلزال الاخير وطرد بعض الضحايا الذين تم
ايوائهم في الفنادق يوظف الرجلان اوراقهما
الاخيره قبيل الثامن والعشرين من ايار
مايو موعد الحسم في اكثر انتخابات الرئاسه
اثاره في تاريخ تركيا
اذا فثامن والعشرين من هذا الشهر سيتنافس
في جوله الاعاده لحسم الانتخابات الرئاسيه
كل من الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان الذي
يمثل تحالف الجمهور وكمالك الاجداد اورو
الذي يمثل تحالف الشعب المعالج في العرض
التالي نسلط الضوء على كل من التحالفين
يضم تحالف الجمهور الحاكم كلا من حزب
العداله والتنميه وحزب الحركه القوميه حيث
شهد عام 2016 تقاربا سياسيا بين الحزبين
اثر محاوله الانقلاب الفاشل لصيف ذاك
العام
وفي عام 2018 ولد تحالف الجمهور رسميا حين
خاض الحزبان انتخابات اثمرت فوز اردوغان
بمنصب رئيس الجمهوريه وفوزه تحالفه
باغلبيه برلمانيه التحالف وان كانت سمته
القوميه محافظه فقد توسع في الانتخابات
الحاليه ليضم كلا من حزب الرفاه من جديد
بزعامه فاتح اربكان اضافه الى احزاب داعمه
ابرزها حزب الدعوه الحر او الهدى وحزب
اليسار الديمقراطي وحزب الطريق القوي وحزب
تركيا الكبرى من ابرز اجندات التحالف
الانتخابيه تمسكه بالنظام الرئاسي
باعتباره ضامنا للاستقرار السياسي
اجتماعيا يدعم التحالف اجراء تعديل دستوري
بشان الحجاب لحمايه الحقوق والحريات
الاساسيه وفي حقل قانون الاسره يدعو
لتعريف واضح بشان تشكيل الاسره من جنسين
مختلفين حصرا في السياسه الخارجيه يتمسك
التحالف بعلاقات طيبه مع المحيط الاقليمي
واخرى استراتيجيه مع الغرب لان تركيا جزء
من حلف كما يدعو الى الاستمرار في لعب دور
وسطي بين الحلفاء الشرقيين والغربيين في
المقابل يحتشد خصوم الرئيس اردوغان في
تحالف الشعب الذي ضم اطيافا سياسيه
متباينه على راس هذا التحالف حزب الشعب
الجمهوري اكبر احزاب المعارضه واقدم
الاحزاب التركيه يراسه كمالك الاجدار
اوغلو كما يضم التحالف حزب الجيد وهو حزب
وسطي قومي اسسته وما زالت تتراسه ميرال
اكشنار القياديه السابقه في حزب الحركه
القوميه ويضم التحالف كذلك حزب السعاده
وهو حزب محافظ خرج من رحم حزب الرفاه
ويراسه حاليا تم الكرم الله اوغلو ومن
الاحزاب المنضويه تحت تحالف الشعب الحزب
الديمقراطي وهو حزب قومي وسطي كما يضم
التحالف حزب المستقبل برئاسه الرئيس
الوزراء السابق احمد داوود اوغلو وحزب
الديمقراطيه والتقدم برئاسه نائب رئيس
الوزراء السابق علي بابا جان الخصومه
الشديده مع الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان حزبه
والرغبه في اقصائهما عن الحكم هو ما وحد
هذا التحالف غير المتجانس فكريا
وايضولوجيا ابرز اجندات التحالف اعلانه
انه سيعمل على العوده الى النظام
البرلماني الذي يقلص صلاحيات الرئيس لصالح
عوده منصب رئيس الوزراء يحمل التحالف
اردوغان مسؤوليه الانهيار المالي وتهاوي
الليره والارتفاع التاريخي في معدل التضخم
ويتهمه بالتسبب في تدهور الاوضاع المعيشيه
للمواطنين ويرى التحالف ان طموحات اردوغان
الشخصيه ادت الى تسمم علاقات تركيا
بالشركاء الغربيين والخليجيين في السنوات
الاخيره اما قضيه ملايين اللاجئين
السوريين فهي القضيه الجوهريه في برنامج
التحالف حيث يخطط التحالف لاعادتهم الى
سوريا خلال عامين وفقا للتعهد رئيسه كمالك
الجدار اوغلو
دكتور علي بكير اهلا وسهلا بك في هذه
الجوله الثانيه برايك كيف تبدو حظوظ
المرشحين يعني اعتقد من الناحيه النظريه
حدود المرشحين لا تزال قائمه حتى الانتخاب
الجوله الثانيه لكن من الناحيه العمليه
اعتقد ان حظوظ الرئيس اردوغان اعلى من
حظوظ خصمه
لدينا الان
انتصار في البرلمان وهذا الامتصاص سيعطي
دفعه معنويه لانصار الرئيس ولدينا كتله
كتله التحالف الذي تحالف الجمهور الذي
يمثل حزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس كتله
متماسكه ومنسجمه وتدعم رجل واحد ولدينا
ايضا جمهور متحفز لحسم النتيجه في المرحله
الثانيه لكن لكن مع هذه العوامل القويه
المتواجده يخشى يعني انا لاحظت خلال
الايام القليله الماضي ان هناك ربما البعض
يعتقد ان هناك فوز سهل لذلك اذا ما كان
هذا الاعتق واسعا ربما يؤدي الى تقاعس
قاعده الشعبيه وعدم الذهاب للصندوق وفي
هذه الحلقه تحصل مفاجات لكن انا اعتقد ان
اي من الطرفين سيترك الامور للصدفه
وسيعملان على الحشد من الناحيه الاخرى
المرشح كمال
هم حقيقه اصيموا اصيبوا بصدمه كبيره في
النتائج لانهم كانوا يتوقعون ان يتصلوا من
الجوله الاولى بفارق كبير وبالتالي هناك
احباط الان لدى القاعده الجماهيريه هذا
الاحباط قد يثبت عزيمه القاعده للذهاب
للتصويت وهذا عامل سلبي ايضا لدينا كتله
غير متماسكه تحالف القائم هو تحالف الشعب
او الامه وتحالف غير متماسك هناك تناقضات
كبيره بين مكوناته هناك خلافات يعني ظهرت
الى العلم بعد النتيجه الاولى
ولدينا يعني
حاله نفسيه غير متماسكه لكن في المقابل
اعتقد ان
تحالف الامه الذي يمثله طبعا كمالك لديه
فرصه واحده فقط لا غير في الجوله الثانيه
وهي الحصول على كامل الاصوات التي حصل
عليها في الجوله الاولى بما في ذلك اصوات
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه الكردي المتهم
بانه طبعا متعاطف مع حزب العمال
الكردستاني مصنف ارهابي زائد اصوات
القوميين وعلى راسهم سنان لكن طبعا سنناقش
ما مدى واقعيه مثل هذا الخيار في
حتى نفصل اكثر نسال ضيفنا من انقره سيد
يوسف كان لي اذا كان هناك نوع من شعور
بالخيبه الامل لدى انصار السيد
كل جدار اوغلو ما عدم الفوز في الانتخابات
النيابيه
كيف يمكن له ان يتغلب على هذا الاحساس
هذه مشكله كبيره المشكله الكبيره مداعميك
الجدار لان نتائج انتخابات اللي كانوا
يتوقعونها كان يتوقع ان تكون بفوز كبير
جدا ولكن ما حصل عليك انها 45% وهذه تشكل
خيبه امل كبيره وكما قال ضيفكم الاخر ان
البرلمان
التحالف الحاكم هو الذي لديه الغالبيه
الكبرى في هذا البرلمان وبالتالي هذا عنصر
اضافي لخيبه الامل وبالتالي اعتقد لابد
هناك دفع الى الامام لاثاره حماس الناخبين
للتوجه الى صناديق الاقتراع واليوم غليت
شعر قام بالقاء خطاب مهم جدا
اذ ذكر
الاتراك بما هو في خطر بطريقه شرح الامر
وكان
كان هذا استفتاء بين الحكم الشديد
والديمقراطيه من جانب والديكتاتوريه من
جانب الديمقراطيه والمزيد من اللاجئين
وهكذا وبالتالي فهو بدا بحمله بقوله
هذا الجانب هذه الحكومه في اسوا ظروفها
وضع اقتصادي سيء اعداد متزايده من
اللاجئين والطقراصيه ام تفضلون
الديمقراطيه والعوده
الى المجتمع المتحضر في العالم وبالتالي
يعتقد تدري مناقشات ساخنه
ان لم نقل تظاهرات مناقشات ساخنه في
المجتمع التي قد تؤدي الى الاثاره والشعور
بالحماس وتدفع بالناس لتوجه الى الصناديق
الاقتراع لان ليس فقط حزب المعارضه لكن
هناك ايضا مشكله في الحزب الحاكم ليس فقط
اردوغان وبالتالي الشعور بالفوز مسبقا قد
ياتي بمفاجاه غير ساره بالنسبه اليهم
اولا بالنسبه لمواطن التركي الصوت وادلاء
الصوت يعتبر مساله وطنيه ثانيا مساله ارض
وناموس يعني لذلك لا يمكن ان يكون هناك
تراخي او تراجع عن ما قاموا به من الجوله
الاولى وبالتالي الحماسه حماسه
الشعب المؤيد الذي اردوغان ما زال
قائم وبالتالي لا يمكن ان يكون هناك اي
تراجع في مستوى الشعبي في التصويت نحن كنا
نخاف بشكل عام في مناطق الزلزال
مناطق المنكوبه من الزلزال ان لا يكون
هناك تصويت حتى في مناطق الزلزال لم يكن
هناك في الجوله الاولى اي خلل في في
التصويت وبالتالي انا اعتقد كما صوتوا في
الجوله الاولى سوف يصوتون مره ثانيه قد
يكون فقط في بعض الدول الاوروبيه لان في
دول الاوروبيه خارج تركيا اقصد وصول الى
مناطق الاخضراء يكون صعبه يعني الوصول
اليه صعب هذا التراجع قد يكون من طرف من
حزب الشعب الجمهوري اكثر من اتباع حزب
العداله والتنميه في خارج تركيا هناك ايضا
مساله مهمه دكتور بكير ربما خارج الحسابات
السياسيه هي قضيه الحضور ما يسمى
بالكاريزما يعني كثيرون يشيرون الى ان
كاريزمه اردوغان طاغيه على كاريزمه وهذا
سيلعب دورا ايضا مؤثرا في العمليه
والخبره طريقه التعاطي ايضا مع الجمهور
امر مهم للغايه في هذه المرحله هناك كانت
طبعا انتقادات
كماله مؤخرا حتى عندما خرج يعني لتحفيز
جمهوره وارتدى القبه القبعه القوميه كان
هناك من ينتقدون ان يحمل الورقه ويقرا
منها في المقابل نحن نعرف اردوغان يعني
خبره كبيره ايضا الفريق المح غيروا الفريق
وغير التيم وغير حتى الخلفيه يعني وضع
صوره مختلفه ووضع السواره وهذه كلها كانت
طبعا رسائل الى الجمهور الذي يحاول
الاستقطابه في الجوله الثانيه لكن اعتقد
ايضا انه مساله مساله الكاريزما هذه يعني
في عوامل اهم الان منها وهي المواضيع التي
كل طرف يحاول استهدافه يعني واضح الان
المعارضه بقياده كمال كينش وتحاول استهداف
نقاط الضعف لدى فريق الرئيس اردوغان وحزب
العداله والتنميه والتحالف الذي يمثله على
راسها موضوع اللاجئين ثم موضوع الاقتصاد
لانه هناك ضغط كبير من الناحيه الاقتصاديه
وهم يحاولين يعني استثمار هذا الوضع في
تحفيز ولكن لم يعطي نتيجه يعني مساله
التشهير بالوضع الاقتصادي لم عمليا لم
يؤثر كثيرا لم صحيح صحيح لكن لم يعطي
نتيجه لان التكتيكات التي تبعها يعني
تحالف الامه وكما تشترك كانت خاطئه وعلى
راسها التحالف مع حزب يعني مقرب من او
بطاعات حزب العمال الكردستاني المتهم
بالارهاب هذا كان له ارتدادات سلبيه
للغايه واعتقد ان الامر اذا ما ظل في نفس
يعني السياق سيكون له نتائج سلبيه لكن في
الغالب هم يحاولون استهداف نقاط الضعف لدى
اردوغان على راسها اللاجئين موضوع
الاقتصاد والعامل الثالث هو تحفيز الشباب
خاصه ان نسبه كبيره منهم حوالي 5 مليون
الذين يصوتون لاول مره هؤلاء نسبه كبيره
منهم تسوق الان للمعارضه ويريدون ان يروا
تغيير في البلاد لذلك انا اعتقد هذه نقاط
الضعف سيستهدفونها في المقابل طبعا
اردوغان وتحالفه ويحاولون التركيز على
مساله تحالف كماله
وتحالف الامه مع جماعات ارهابيه
وايضا يعني يحاولون التصوير التنازلات
التي يقدمها هذا الجانب في موضوع مثلا
ربما استقلاليه اكبر في المناطق التي
يتواجد بها اخراج متهمين بالارهاب من
السجون
والى خلافه هذه مهمه هذه القضيه قضيه مهمه
للمواطن التركي بشكل عام خاصه القوميين
منه وبالتالي هذه ورقه قويه بيد الرئيس هل
هناك ورقه ربما قد تكون اقوى وهي ان
اردوغان وتحالف فاز في الانتخابات
النيابيه وبالتالي فمن اجل ضمان استقرار
البلاد ان يكون هناك تناغم بين المؤسسه
الرئاسه والبرلمان لان
ربما المواطن التركي قد يخاف ان صعد
كل جدار اوغلو ان يسمح هناك تنافر بين
البرلمان وبين رئيس لا يستطيع ان يفعل
شيئا في النهايه صحيح هكذا الكلام صحيح
سيكون هناك مازق ولا اعتقد اصلا ان
المعارضه فكرت في هذا السيناريو هم لم
يكونوا طبعا مستعدين لهذا السيناريو كانوا
يعتقدون ان هناك فوز كاسح من الجوله
الاولى انا اعتقد حتى لو فازوا نظريا في
في الجوله الثانيه سيكون هناك الرئيس
يمثلك برلمان تابع
لتحالف حزب العداله والتنميه وسيكون في
مازق لانهم يدعون الى تغيير النظام
الرئاسي لنظام برلماني وهو لا يستطيع ان
يفعل ذلك الاغلبيه البرلمانيه في يد حزب
العداله والتنميه واذا ما غير يعني ان
رئيس الوزراء سيكون من حزب سيكون هناك
مشكله كبيره اعتقد الان ان التصويت يجري
على امور اخرى له علاقه بالهويه لها علاقه
بتوجهات الايديولوجيه لها علاقه بمستقبل
البلاد وهي اهم من السيناريو الموضع الذي
سيد يوسف كان في انقره هل هذا المازق بين
قوسين سيلعب ضد السيد لانه حتى وان فاز لا
يستطيع ان يفي بالوعود التي قطعها على
نفسه لا سيما موضوعه تغيير
نمط الحكم في البلاد
[موسيقى]
تركيا اياما عصيبه مستقبلا لان الخزانه
فاضيه والوضع الاقتصادي بشكل سيء وبصرف
النظر من عن من سيفوز لابد على تركيا ان
تتخذ اجراءات التقشفيه قاسيه جدا هذا امر
مؤكد والشيء الثاني ضيفكم في الاستوديو لم
يقدم
الذي قدمت الموضوع بشكل جديد بما يتعلق
بالداعمي ثم لك
اولا هو ليس في تحالف
كريستال اوغلو هو يدعمونه الاقليص اظن
التحالفه وثانيا مجموعه
لم تتعد بعفو واعفاء عفو هذه معلومه شرها
اردوغان نفسه وهي كذبه
علينا ان نوضح ذلك ثالثا اردوغان
[موسيقى]
لديه حليف خطير جدا وهذا امر رسمي فاثناء
من اعضاء حزب حزب الله انت في البرلمان
وهذا خطر جدا لان هذا يعني اول مره حزب
الله سيمثل في البرلمان التركي بضوين
الرئيس والشخص لاعب اخر وبالتالي دعونا
نكون صريحين فيما عندما نقوم بالتقييمات
المشكله هي
ليست من هنا المشكله الحقيقيه هي الاقتصاد
من صرف النظر عن من سيفوز وانا البرلمان
سيطر عليه مجموعه واحده والحكومه تسيطر
عليها
جهه تنفيذيه تكون طرف اخر قد تكون ذلك
فرصه لتركيا
لتمهيد الطريق والعوده المصالحه ومحاوله
التوصل الى توافق يحكم البلاد نحن نحتاجه
جدا لانه تحت اردوغان كان هناك
السياسات مستمره يمليها شخص واحد وهذا هو
السبب الرئيسي لوجود
المعارضه فهم ضد حكم الرجل الواحد
واذا اذا كانت البرلمان ضمن المعارضه فاذا
كنت كفر فرصه لتركيا لتتغير وثانيا حتى
حزب اردوغان
يميل الى تغيير النظام الى النظام
البرلماني مره اخرى اذا ما خسروا الرئاسه
لانه انذاك سيكون ذلك لصالحهم وبالتالي في
السياسه 24 ساعه مده طويله جدا وعلينا ان
ننتظر نتائج الانتخابات قبل ان نقدم مثل
هذا التحليل على على الارجاح اردوغان
سيفوز في هذه الانتخابات انا اتفق مع
ضيفكم لان
لان
ذلك فقلنا انه ان البرلمان فيه غالبيه من
اعضاءه حز اردوغان فلابد
الحكم على اردوغان على الارجح ولكن من جهه
اخرى لن يكن نهايه العالم وربما تكون هناك
فرص اخرى يقدمها
هناك عنصر مهم سيد عمر فاروق
هؤلاء الناس الذين لم يذهبوا الى التصويت
طبعا التصويت نسبه المشاركه كانت نسبه
عاليه وقياسيه ولكن هناك على الاقل وفق ما
قاله السيد علي بابا جان رئيس حزب
الديمقراطيه والتقدم هناك 8.5 مليون تركي
لم يذهبوا الى التصويت هل هناك تخوفات من
ان هؤلاء ليسوا بالضروره مضمونين
للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
يعني هناك من لم يسب اكيد لاسباب ما وهذه
المره ايضا هناك من لا يذهب لكن انا اقول
الذين كما قلت قبل قليل الذين تمسكوا
بتحالفهم
وايدوايدون او يصوتون مره ثانيه وبالتالي
هؤلاء الذين لم ينسبوا قد لم يسبوا جوز
كبير منهم ايضا يعني لكن هل لا نستطيع ان
نقول ان ان النتيجه
فيها ضمانه لاردوغان لا احد يقول ذلك لكن
الصوره النهائيه التي ظهرت في جوله الاولى
يبدو ان اردوغان محظوظ اكثر بالنسبه
ان هناك بدات هناك الان نقاش عميق وخطير
جدا في داخل التحالف الشعب او المله بان
الاحزاب الذين دخلوا في البرلمان عن ظهر
حزب الشعب الجمهوري الان هم مرتاحون ليس
لديهم مشكله ولا يهمهم الرئاسه ولا يهمهم
رئاسه
ما يهمهم الان هم ادخلوا أناصرهم اعضائهم
في البرلمان وبالتالي 39 عضو من احزاب
مختلفه الثلاثه والرابعه اربعه الذين
ادخلوا اعضائهم في البرلمان هؤلاء ايضا
اغلبهم محافظين فبالتالي هذه ايضا قضيه
حساسه في داخل حزب الشعب الجمهوري يعني
كثير من من
العناصر المحاضره من اتباع حزب الشعب
جمهوري لن يستطيع ان يرشحوا في هذه
الانتخابات هذه المسائله بدات في داخل حزب
الشعب الجمهوري وان كان في خلال اسبوعين
ربما يظهر قليلا لكن في نقاش حاد بينما
اردوغان
تحالف الجمهور ليس لديها ادنى مشكله
ومتماسكين جدا ويعتبرون ان هذه
الجوله الثانيه
اصبحت اخطر من جوله الاولى وبالتالي سوف
يذهب الى الصناديق ايضا هناك طبعا في هذه
الجوله الثانيه
المعارضه او مجموعه التحالف شعب سوف يثير
مشكله اللاجئين نعم صحيح لكن خلال يومين
انا الاحظ ان لغه تغير تغيرت بشكل كبير
الكولسترول الذي كان لطيف طيب مبتسم اصبح
رجل شرس وتغيرت لغه تغيرت لغته بشكل عنيف
جدا وهذا سيؤثر على ناخب التركي لان لن
يكون هناك يعني التوجه ايجابي كما كانت في
الجوله الاولى ايضا وبالتالي يعني هو
سيركز على اللاجئين لكن اردوغان سيركز على
الامن والتقدم والتكنولوجيا
الهدف الذي كان يريدون اسقاط اردوغان ربما
الان بات بعيدا ليس مس جوله الاولى ثانيا
اكشنر كان كانت تريد ان تكون رئيسه
الوزراء في كل حملاته كانت تقول انا ساكون
رئيسه الوزراء في نظام البرلماني لكن الان
بعد ان تشكلت البرلمان
يعني الان خيبت ظن ظن اكشنري انتهت هذه
المساله لان الاغلبيه
او تحالف تحالف الجمهور فبالتالي لا يمكن
ان تكون رئيسه الوزراء حتى حتى اذا اصبحت
يعني يعني بعض الانتخابات في جوله الثانيه
نعم الى حد الان لم نتحدث عن سنان اوغن
سنان اوغان الذي حل ثالثا بنسبه 5%
وصفه البعض بانه الان اصبح
بيضه القبان
البعض اطلق عليه حتى لقب صنع ملوك سنرى
الى حد هذا صحيح لنتعرف في هذه الورقه عن
سنان اوغان
ولد عام
1967 في مدينه اغديره التركيه
ينتمي الى التيار القومي وهو مرشح تحالف
الاجداد الذي يضم احزابا قوميه يمنيه
اهمها حزب النصر عام 2015 اعلن اوغان
ترشحه لرئاسه حزب الحركه القوميه ولكنه
طرد من الحزب لكن قرار الطردي الغي قضائيا
بعد اشهر قليله في مارس ادار 2017 طرد من
الحزب مجددا مع ثلاثه من نواب الحزب
لدعوتهم الى التصويت بلا في الاستفتاء على
التعديل الدستوري الذي افضى الى التحول
البلاد الى نظام رئاسي والغاء منصب رئيس
الوزراء استطاع اوغان جمع اكثر من 100 الف
توقيع يحتاجها المرشح لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه عام 2023
وكانت ابرز وعده الانتخابيه الغاء نظام
الرئاسي والعمل على اعاده اللاجئين وتعزيز
الجوانب الانتاجيه في الاقتصاد ودعم
الزراعه حصل اوغان على اكثر من 5% من
اصوات الناخبين في جوله انتخابات رئاسه
الاولى وهو ما يناهز مليونين و800 الف صوت
دكتور علي بكير سنان اوغان
هل تعتقد بانه سيكون فعلا قادر على ترجيح
ايا من الكفتين اسمح لي بدايه اعلق بشكل
سريع على التعليق اللي سمعته يعني انا قلت
من البدايه ان نظريا حظوظ الطرفين قائمه
حتى التصويت لكن عمليا حظوظ اردوغان اقوى
بحكم الواقع والتحليل يعني
لديه فرصه واحده فقط لا غير وهذه الفرصه
الصعبه للغايه الان كل طرف يستهدف نقاط
ضعف الطرف الاخر هم يقولون ان هذا يدعى
يدعم الارهاب والطرف الاخر يقول ان هذا
يدعم الارهاب لكن راينا ان لا نروج لاوهام
ونقع في اخطاء كما حصل في السابقه وننصدم
بالنتيجه هناك تصريحات رسميه علنيه
بالتصويت لحزب اليسار الاخضر وكمان وهناك
قاده من حزب العمال الكردستاني موجود
التسجيل على الانترنت باستطاع يعني الجميع
يمكن ان يشاهده
فيما يتعلق بسؤالك انا اعتقد ان دور سنان
اوغان مبالغ فيه الى حد ما هو يصبح مهم
جدا اذا ما تكرر سيناريو الجوله الاولى
بمعنى
الوحيد امامك نشتري اوغلو هو ان يعد اوغان
بمنصب وزاري وربما رئاسه ايضا نائب رئيس
وان يدفع حزب اليسار الاخضر او حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي الكردي لدعمه بشكل مبطن وليس
علني لانه نحن قبل الجوله الاولى بعشر
ايام تحول الدعم المبطن الى دعم علني وهذا
الضر كثيرا بحظوظ كمال كريستال اوغلو
والتحالف الذي يقوده اذا ما تحول هذا
الدعم الى دعم مبطن وفي نفس الوقت حصل
كمان يشتغلوا على دعم سنان عندها حدوده
تزداد لكن هذا لا يضمن له ايضا الانتصار
ولكن سنان اوغان يقول لديه خطان احمر
احمران موضوع الارهاب وموضوع اللاجئين
موضوع الارهاب هو يتعلق بالمعارضه هكذا
تقريبا على اساس هذه العلاقه مع الاكراد
بالنسبه للاجئين هذا موضوع يتعلق باردوغان
وبالتالي لديه مشكله سواء ذهب الى هنا او
الى هناك طبعا هو الان هو يتفاوض هو كان
هدفه الاساسي من الترشح كان ان يدفع
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه الى جوله ثانيه حتى
يفاوض الطرفين على مكاسب هو يريدها من
ناحيه الارهاب طبعا كل طرف يعني يدعي ان
الطرف الاخر متحالف مع الارهاب من ناحيه
اللاجئين طبعا هذه نقطه ضعف كبيره بالنسبه
الى فريق اردوغان لكن تبين في الجوله
الاولى انها لم تكن بالاهميه التي كان
البعض يعتقد انها عليه وبالتالي التصويت
سيكون ايضا ايديولوجيا من الصعب جدا اقناع
القوميين بدعم تحالف الذي يقوم يقودك
بدليل ان الحزب الجيد تقوده حصل على نسبه
متدينه متدنيه جدا مقارنه بالتوقعات التي
كانت قائمه قبل يعني البعض كان يتوقع ان
يحصل هذا على 15% حتى البعض بالغ وقال 20%
لكن الان تسعه بالمئه هذا دليل على انه من
الصعب ان تحوز على اصوات القوميين في هذه
الجهه فالجهه الاخرى حدودها اعلى في ان
تكسب القومين وهي ربما ليست بحاجه ماسه
الى اصوات سنان اوغان كما سبق وشرحنا لكن
طبعا هذه كلها تقديرات في النهايه الامر
سيعتمد على الواقع سيد يوسف
ان يستميل اوغان
اعتقد
انهم سيلتقون غدا بمناسبه
فهناك اجتماع متوقع بينهما غدا على الارجح
سيتوصلان الى اتفاق المجموعه التامه
قريبتان بعضهما عدا ما قاله ضيفكم الاخ ما
يتعلق موضوع الكردي لكن الاكراد كما قلت
ليسوا في تحالف لبلد يدعمون التحالف
وبالتالي ليس مشكله كبيره جدا وبالتالي
اعتقد ان
اوغان ومجموعاته يدعمونك كشتان اوغلو ولكن
ذلك لن يسهل الامر بالنسبه
لانه اولا
لا يستطيع ان يحصل كل اصوات اللي حصل
عليها لا يعطيها كلها فهذه اصوات وصلت
الردوده افعال وهي اصوات ضد اردوغان او ضد
كريشنال اوغلو او ضد امور اخرى كثيره
وبالتالي كيف سيصوتون هو امر غامض بالنسبه
لنا جميعا
لا يعني كثيرا او
اوغلو لا يعني شيئا كثيرا فمجموعته تقرر
بنفسها من لمن تصوت وعلى انهم لن يشاركوا
في الانتخابات وبالتالي لو كان نقل الكثير
من المشاركه
فرمتكون هناك
فرصه افضل اردوغان
ولك لو ان مجموعه الدخان كما قلت في
البدايه
بسبب
المبالغه بالثقه بالنفس لم يتوجه ناخبوها
الى صناديق
سيكون لصالح كريستال اوغلو وبالتالي يوم
الانتخابات سنعرف اي ايهما اقرب للنصر
الان نستطيع نقول ان اردوغان اقرب الى
النصر ببوصه واحده يعني كررتها اكثر من
مره على كل
سنرى ذلك اكثر في خلال النقاش سيد كركماز
بالنسبه
سيد اردوغان هل تعتقد بانه معني جدا
بالتحصيل على
اصوات
التي سندت سيد اوغان اذا كانت فعلا ليست
كتله وليست متجانسه وقد لا تكون موجوده
اصلا في الجوله الثانيه مثل ما اشار ضيفنا
السيد يوسف كانلي
انا اتفق تماما مع ضيفكم استاذ يوسف ولا
ان قواعد السيلان اوران ليس ليس ليست
قواعد صلبه وبالتالي هذه القواعد متراويحه
ربما يسب جزء منها الى حزب الشعب الجمهوري
وان كان هذه ستكون قله لكن ربما
سوف يذهب الى حزب العداله والتنميه او لن
يصوته اصلا يعني اذا صوت او لا يصوتوا
اصلا يعني حصول على النتيجه النهائيه
اردوغان يعني بقي له قليل جدا اما بالنسبه
للكوليسترول امامه على الاقل خمسه او سته
بالمئه من الاصوات هذا سيخز يعني صعوبه
كبيره جدا وبالتالي حليف النصر غالبا
غالبا سيكون لكن هذا ليس فيه الضمان هناك
تركيا فيه تقلبات كثيره خلال اسبوعين نحن
لا نعرف ما الذي سيحدث لكن اهم شيء الان
السينال اوغان
فيدخل في اختبار الاولى سواء في اتباعه او
في سياسه التركيه وبالتالي اما سيبقى في
ساحه السياسيه في تركيا او سيزول تماما
كما انتهى غيره في مجال السياسي لاحظنا
شيئا في موضوع النقاش السياسي الان في
تركيا الدكتور علي بكير موضوع
الوضع الاقتصادي تراجع نوعا ما الحديث عن
تراجع الليره والتضخم الى اخره تراجع نوعا
ما عاد موضوع اللاجئين بقوه عدم موضوع
التعامل مع مناطق الزلزال يعني الرئيس
اردوغان
البلديات التي هي في جنوب البلاد بانها
اثرت تصويت عاملت جمهور الناخبين هناك
معامله مختلفه اخرجتهم من الفنادق لم تعد
تعطيهم بعض المنح بسبب تصويتهم موضوع
اللاجئين ايضا استغلوا
جدار اوغلو بالحديث بان الرئيس اردوغان
فتح الباب لعشره ملايين تساهل في موضوع
منح الجواز موضوع اللاجئين يمكن ان يلعب
دورا اهم من الجوله الاولى طبعا موضوع
اللاجئين موضوع مهم جدا بدليل ان الجميع
يستهدف هذا الموضوع بما في ذلك المعارضه
وحتى هو بنى كل حملته على موضوع اللاجئين
بالدرجه الاولى وموضوع اللاجئين ايضا
مرتبط بعده عناصر اخرى من بينها العامل
الاقتصادي يعني العامل الاقتصادي جزء
اساسي من التحريض على اللاجئين هو ان
هؤلاء اللاجئين سبب في التدهور الاقتصادي
وانهم ياخذون فرص من فرص الاتراك اعتقد ان
طريقه الخطاب ايضا الذي القاه كمالك يوم
امس انتقدت حتى من بعض اطراف المعارضه
لانه هناك من راى بانه خطاب الشوفيني
عنصري مبالغ فيه الى حد كبير هو قال ان
هناك طبعا 10 مليون في اللاجئ في البلاد
وانه يعني هذا هذا الرقم قد يتحول الى 30
مليون مستقبلا وهذا طبعا امور غير واقعيه
يعني غير حقيقي هذا الموضوع وبالتالي هو
عن اراد ان يلعب على هذا الوتر لجذب اصوات
قوميه الملاحظ ان فريق اردوغان تمسك
بسياسه مختلفه يعني الرئيس قبل الانتخابات
بيوم كان يقول انه لا يمكن ان ندفع هؤلاء
الى يعني الاجرام والى العوده لكي يقتلوا
وكان هذا طبعا تصريح خطير لانه ممكن يؤثر
على على الناخبين وبشكل سلبي ويعني يخفض
من النتيجه لكن لم نرى هذا التخفيض بشكل
كبير وهذا ايضا يضع علامه استفهام على مدى
يعني اساسيه الموضوع للانتخب التركي لكن
لا شك ان هذا الموضوع لدى شريحه واسعه من
القوميين طبعا الراي العام التركي اليوم
هو راي عام محافظ ويميني في الغالب
وبالتالي شريحه القومين موقفها موقفها مهم
جدا لدى الطرفين في يعني في الحسابات
الانتخابيه موضوع الاقتصاد موضوع قائم
ايضا والمعارضه تركز عليه وتحاول استهدافه
وموضوع كما ذكرنا شريحه الشباب حوالي خمسه
مليون هؤلاء في غلبي يصوتوا
للمعارضه لانهم يريدون ان يروا تغييرا في
البلاد هم طبعا لم يروا كيف كان الوضع
عليه ما قبل حزب العداله والتنميه وكيف
كانت البلاد حتى موضوع الشباب الدكتور
بكير هناك مبالغه في تحفيزه يعني مثلا
تصريح
لكل جدار اوغلو يتحدث فيه يوجه كلامه
للشباب يقول لهم لن تستعيدوا شبابكم مره
اخرى
امامنا 12 يوما يجب ان نخرج من هذا النفق
المظلم يعني اصبح انتقل الامر من تحفيز
الشباب الى تخويفه هذا ربما يلعب دور
معاكسه يعني جزء من الحمله التخويف هو ان
يدفع الناخب للتصويت لصالحه لكن المشكله
انه يعني خلال فتره قصيره جدا حصلت هناك
تحولات كبيره في خطاب كماله والتحالف الذي
يمثله يعني انتقلهم من من العلمانيه
المتشدده الى
اللايت اسلام ثم الى
القوميه المتطرفه هناك انتقال يعني بين
الايديولوجيات وهذا ايضا قد يعني يرسل
رساله سلبيه النخب قد لا يثق بما يقولونه
او يعيدون به بدليل انهم يعني يقفزون من
منطقه الى اخرى ربما هذا يكون صحيحا سنرى
طبعا من خلال التصويت سيعكس اذا ما هذا
كان الامر صحيحا ام لا لكن هذه وجهه النظر
موجوده وقائمه وهناك من يقول لا انه هذا
لن يؤثر وهو يحاول استهداف الشريحه التي
يحتاج اليها في هذه المرحله بالتحديد كي
يرفع من حظوظه للانتصار في الجوله الثانيه
مناطق الزلزال سيد يوسف
هل تعتقد بانها ستدعم اكثر رجب طيب
اردوغان لانها على الاقل هو وعدها باشياء
يجب ان تتابع معه تنفيذ هذه الوعود وربما
هذه المعامله التي لقيها البعض من قبل
بلديات هناك تسيطر عليها المعارضه ستؤجز
غضب معين ضد المعارضه في الجوله الثانيه
[موسيقى]
اولا لو نظرنا الى منطقه الزلازل فاعداها
تاعي فان اردوغان وحزبه
حصلوا على القياده
والتقدم في كل المدن وبالتالي فافتراض انه
رغم الزلزال
فان منطقه المصابه
بالانتقلت
لتدعم اردوغان هذا ليس صحيح نعم في هاتاي
كان
كان انتصار اردوغان كبيرا جدا والان لدينا
اردوغان يزداد قوه في مناطق اخرى ايضا قد
تكون هناك عده اسوا وراء ذلك
ولكن
تمت امر اهم من انتخابات في مثل هذه
الحالات فمنطقه الزلزال بحاجه الى دعم
وبحاجه الى الحب وبحاجه الى كل انواع
المساعده
وبمثل هذا
هذه التوجه والفهم الطائفي
والاستبعاد قد نؤذي بعض الناس وبالتالي
انا امتنع عن الدخول في نقاش حول
مزاج الناس الذين يعيشون في منطقه الزلزال
فهم لذلك بصف نضع التفكيرهم وعلينا ان
نعرف ان نفكر بهم بشكل اخر نعم كان قرار
قرارهم وهم يرون ان الحكومه هل يرى دعم
الحكومه لهم مرضي ربما تقول المعارضه بان
دعم الدوله لم يكن كافيا لا يمكن نناقش
ذلك حقيقه هناك
اشار اليها الدكتور بكير قبل قليل اشار
الى ان الشباب الذين يتذمرون من الوضع
الاقتصادي الحالي ربما لم يعيشوا تركيا
قبل عشرين عاما كيف كان وضعها الاقتصادي
ومكانتها الاقليميه والدوليه ضعيفه للغايه
هذا يقودني الى سؤال
تركيا الان اصبحت لاعبا اقليميا
هاما ولعبا دوليا كذلك وهناك شعاع دولي
لتركيا ودور لم يكن لها في السابق هل
تعتقد بان هذه المساله
تعني الكثيرين في تركيا وبالتالي قد تلعب
دورا فاعلا في التصويت للسيد اردوغان
اولا قبل الانتخابات وقبل جوله الاولى
كثير من الناس كثير من المحللين كانوا
يقولون ان الشباب لن يصوتوا لحزب العداله
والتنميه لان الشباب الجدد لا يعرفون ان
خدمات التي قدمتها
حزب والتنميه لكن ظهرت في الانتخابات يبدو
ان عدد كبير من الشباب
صوتوا لحزب التنميه او في تحالف والجمهور
لان
مهرجانات التي اقامتها
عناصر حزب الاداله والتنميه مثل
المهرجان التكنولوجي وظهور التركيه خاصه
في الدفاع الجوي وايضا نجاحات الميدانيه
سواء في ليبيا او في كندا وما الى ذلك كل
هذا اعطت زخما جديدا بعدا جديدا لشباب
التركي وبالتالي حتى الشباب يبحثون عن
الذين يبحثون عن مستقبلهم بداوا يؤيدون
حزب الاداله والتنميه هذه النقطه الاولى
النقطه الثانيه نعم هناك قطاع كبير من
الشاب لا مباليين الذين لا ينتمون الى اي
طرف سياسي في تركيا هذا كثير هم ربما
الاكثريه لكن من حيث التاطير من حيث
التنظيم شبابي لا توجد هناك لا يوجد هناك
تنظيما سياسيا مثل تنظيم شباب
الله حزب الشعب الجمهوري الى كل الاحزاب
السياسيه حتى من حيث العدد ومن حيث
الترتيب ومن حيث الاداره لا يوجد هناك
تنظيما شبابيه سياسيه مثل شباب تنظيم
وبالتالي هم الذين اصلا اشتغلوا في اثناء
الانتخابات نقطه اخرى
الان اكبر من اردوغان باربع سنوات تقريبا
وهو كيف سيمثل الشباب
اكثر شابا منه يعني حتى في مشروعه وفي
مشروع الحضاري له يعني في نهايه البرنامج
دكتور بكير
رغم كل هذه التحليلات هل يبقى هناك خوف من
عنصر مفاجاه سواء في هذا الاتجاه او ذاك
طبعا بشكل سريع انا عندما نتحدث عن الشباب
نحن نتحدث عن الشريحه الشباب التي دخلت
للمره الاولى للتصويت هؤلاء في الغالب
يعني التقدير انهم يصوتون المعارضه حتى
كان هناك تصريحات من حزب العداله
والتنوجهون صعوبات في جذبهم يعني باتجاههم
المفارقه ايضا ان فئه الفئه العمريه
الكبيره من المصوتين يصوتوا في الغالب
بحزب العداله والتنميه انهم خبروا حكم
طبعا الفريق الاخر ما قبل حزب العداله
والتنميه ولديه ذاكره سلبيه عن هذه
التجربه فيما يتعلق بسؤالك بالتحديد اعتقد
ان الامور نظريه مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات
لا يزال هناك فرصه لكلا المرشحين لتحقيق
تقدم لكن كما شرحنا احد المرشحين كما
اشتروا لديه فرصه واحده وهذه الفرصه يجب
ان يتوافر فيها عده شروط اولا ان يحصل على
دعم مبطن من قبل حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه
الكردي ولكنها صعبه جدا صعبه جدا يجب ان
نحصل على عده شروط اولا دعم من هذا الحزب
ثانيا صفقه مع سنان اوغان ثالثا ان يامل
ان يكون هناك تقاعس لدى قاعده حزب العداله
والتحالف الذي يمثله الرئيس اردوغان
ورابعا المراهنه على الحظ وهذه العناصر
صعبه للغايه ان تجتمع لكن نظريا متاحه نحن
سنرى في نهايه المطاف من الذي سيفوز
سننتظر ونرى شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور علي بكير
شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من اسطنبول عمر فاروق
كركماز ولضيفنا من انقره يوسف كاندي بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه سنرى في الثامن والعشرين من
هذا الشهر ما هي ما هو السيناريو الذي فرض
نفسه في النهايه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]